good to see the judicial Council here
you're welcome to come forward I know we
had some questions and we hadn't quite
finished with your presentation so we
thought giving you a little extra time
today would be beneficial to all of us
anyone following this is on page 537 I
believe in the budget
so it's all yours and I apologize that
we're don't have many members here today
but for one reason or another the
lights up
there you go thank you
for the record my name is Richard
samparrell I'm the acting executive
director of the New Hampshire judicial
Council and uh thank you Mr chairman and
other members of the committee for the
opportunity to come back today and uh
further uh explain to you our budget
request and to answer any questions you
had
when we left off last week we were
um
talking about different account lines
that are covered under what I would put
a general heading of child protection
and I think just to maybe get us
oriented this morning I would start by
explaining to the committee that there
are really three different account lines
that are covered by this one is
um the casa line and I spoke to you a
bit about that last week
the next is
non-casa Guardian Ad Litem services
and then the third category is uh what
is also called a guardian ad litem
services but that's a little misleading
because it covers a variety of different
services and expenses that aren't
covered in the other two categories
um I can if you'd like review with you
um the request for funding for Casa I
went through that with you uh last week
but uh as I explained then and I think
you have some additional materials that
were provided this morning uh from Casa
Casa is the preferred provider of
guardian ad litem services in the state
and they're volunteer Advocates receive
uh extensive training extensive
supervision
our relationship with them is as a
result of a private public partnership
and the funding that they received in
this relationship provides children with
uh Guardian advocacy and under this sort
of unique representation and
reimbursement model
um at this point in time uh Casa is
looks like taking about 92 percent of
the new cases that are being opened in
general they've handled about three
quarters 75 percent of the cases
and the other cases that Casa does not
handle are that other line that you see
of non-casa guardian and light of
Services representative McGuire I think
last week you asked me how many uh
individuals are
providing services that are not
associated with Casa so in reviewing
some of our payments for the last three
years since 2021
we have paid a total of 35 different
non-casa gals eight of those are people
that have not worked on more than four
cases so it really is a pool of about
27 28 Guardians
the guardian ad litem
certification board
has a lot more Guardians available but I
think it's important to distinguish
these types of cases child
protection cases from other situations
where there might be Guardians so for
example you might have Guardians in in
divorce cases that are appointed by the
court you might have Guardians in uh
what are called Chin's cases children in
need of services those Guardians are
paid through dcyf
um you might have Guardians and adoption
cases those Guardians are paid through
the administrative office of the court
so when we use this sort of Guardian
heading it covers a lot of different
things but here in these first two
account lines we're talking about
children who are in uh abuse and neglect
cases and then also termination of
parental rights cases which are commonly
called tpr cases and that often is an
extension of those abusive neglect
proceedings
so getting back to the request for Casa
our request here is for additional
funding of two hundred thousand dollars
for each of the two years of the
biennium it's as I said last week
difficult to put a value on the
volunteers but if we were compensating
them for all of the hours and time that
they put into cases
um I think we could
put a cost figure on about eight million
dollars I think in part that's because
Casa volunteers generally spend a lot of
time with their the children that
they're working with they I don't have
statistical information for this but I
think it's fair to say they spend more
time than the court appointed Guardians
had light them they're involved for a
longer period of time and Casa is active
in recruiting and retaining those
volunteers so that they can handle more
of those cases
it's
thank you
um can we connect this to a page or line
in the budget I'm sorry I should have
started that way so the
uh line for uh Casa funding is at the
governor's budget at page 542.
uh and this is
the non-casa gals that's also on 542 and
that line is uh 1101.
and then this I don't want to confuse
things or get ahead of myself or get
ahead of you but uh the third category
of guarding it at Litem funding is 1092
and that's on a different page that's on
okay so now I see it so
um
so we're providing costs of roughly last
time was a little under a million right
000 and you're asking for 200 000 more
um does that work is that right yeah I
think that's correct you're talking
about the so the actual expenditures in
fiscal year 2021 for Casa was
um
926 550 is that what you're looking at
yes and same as for some reason adjusted
authorized for 2023 is the same
right correct yeah so you know part of
that is going to correspond to well what
was a dip in cases during the pandemic I
think there was a lot of
non-reporting or non uh exposure of of
children to the normal people who would
be reporting and we're seeing a return
there to uh reporting rates or case
filings that predated the pandemic so
um there was a period of time where
there was sort of a lull in these child
uh protection cases but that time is
over
okay and so
the you're now saying that the Casas are
92 percent of the cases and these and
the non-casas are eight percent of the
cases no so in terms of recent cases
the order of proceeding is that Casa
because they're the preferred provider
they are appointed first if they can't
take the case then it goes to a non-cosa
guardian ad litem right now or recently
they have been able to accept 92 percent
of the cases that's not to say that they
currently uh represent 92 percent of the
of the children that are involved
um but you know it's a very good
indicator in the sense that they have
been training more volunteers they have
more volunteers to work with and they're
able to take more cases whether that
Trend continues or not I can't predict
for you but I think it's it is safe for
us to assume that they'll continue to
handle at least 75 percent of the cases
yeah
sure so where we where we had a problem
last time was when I looked at
um
the ratios so look at 2024 for example
um for the Casas and 400 000 for the
non-costas
right correct and we think that the
classes are handling 75 percent of the
cases and the non-coses are handling 25
of the cases yes okay
so the ratio between those is roughly 75
if we add it all up
1.526 it is roughly 75 and 25 right so
what's hard for me to understand is I
would think Casas would be a lot cheaper
because they're volunteers
and they're not so so yeah I I so I'm
just that's my disconnect
um I think you're
um
identifying something uh that on paper
looks like we're comparing apples and
apples and I think the reason that Casa
is the preferred provider is because
um they are providing Services
beyond what our expectation or the
reality is for the non-costage ales and
so if we're not only sort of evaluating
an hour by hour budget comparison but
we're also looking at the quality of
what we're getting for our money as
taxpayers uh or for the services I think
the general understanding is that Casa
is providing a higher quality longer
term uh resource but
um
good morning my name is Marsha sink and
I'm the CEO of Casa I'm happy to answer
any additional questions but I think
that Richard has explained fairly well
that the difference
um and I the handout that I gave you has
some relevant numbers in terms of the
cases that we were able to take the
numbers of children we served and things
like the
um the number of contacts that our Casas
had with the children on their cases
they they contacted them over 20 000
times
um they are our Advocates are required
to see every child that they're
appointed to at least once a month many
of them do that more frequently they are
appointed to a case which is a sibling
group that can be one child or it could
be five or six children
they are
incredibly dedicated to this work and
um citizens from across the state of
which last year we had over 600 that are
volunteering of their time and resources
the infrastructure of the organization
however
needs to continue that recruitment the
retention the uh very comprehensive and
lengthy training that they go through
initially ongoing in-service training
and support throughout the the life of
their time as a casa our Casas typically
um there as I sort of call it their life
expectancy with Casa is a little over
four years and our the average length of
any one of our cases is about two and a
half years we have Casas that have been
with us for 15 20 years and those that
will take one case and decide that it
isn't the right volunteer work for them
so
um we're we're constantly getting the
word out and trying to recruit to
ultimately reach our goal of serving 100
of the children in New Hampshire that
need
Acasa Guardian Ad Litem on the child
abuse and neglect cases
further questions thank you so
um is was he right when he said that
um Casas spend more hours in a case than
these non-casa abuse and neglect
category absolutely absolutely and and
the other thing I'd point out is that
Casas only carry one or two cases at a
time and the pay gals that are absorbing
the cases that we can cannot take are
carrying much larger caseloads so
they're not they don't have
um the opportunity to meet as frequently
with the children or spend as much time
on each individual case as our
volunteers do gotcha okay and so I you
don't have any kind of upper limit for
the number of volunteers right you're
constantly looking for perfect people so
you have all that want to do it
basically or were constantly looking for
more because you know people life
changes and um they have to
um resign from the organization but our
classes typically are staying with this
particular case or children from the
very beginning their appointment through
the termination of parental rights if
that's so it's the same case for us
where as for the judicial Council the
pagios it's two separate separate cases
so let's focus on the non-costals
because that one you want the budget to
more than double yeah so I think uh
to begin that conversation it's probably
important for you to know that we have a
pending request with the governor and
Council and with fiscal for an
additional 187
500 in order to pay our current bills
for non-casa gals and so if that gets
approved the revised budget would be 354
656 which is closer in line to the 400
000 that is being requested
I should explain in part that part of
the reason for that increase is the rate
change that has gone into effect in
October
so while we're
um
covering that rate change there is an
expectation that we haven't fully seen
the manifestation of it in our bills yet
because cases are still getting closed
some of those cases uh have billing from
before the rule change so that's the
basis for the four hundred thousand
dollars
are you paying hourly yes that's correct
and what's the new rate it's ninety
dollars
um
so I I think uh representative McGuire's
question sort of addresses what I would
tell you about non-casa Guardians at
Litem the third category here of uh the
guardian ad litem fund just so uh the
committee is over of the understanding
of what they do they are providing
Guardian services in a variety of cases
but they would be
including adult guardianships and
guardianships of children but also
expenses in those cases so this line
which is 1092 and again it's on the
governor's budget at page 539
we have also uh a pending request for
additional funds of 299
000 in order to pay current invoices and
pay for services through the end of
fiscal year 2023 and that'll result in a
revised budget of uh 849
000 for fiscal year 2023.
um
so I uh will note for you that the
request there
um is for
uh
1 million uh 8 000 basically and again
just like the other category of expenses
I was referring to there's a increase
here in terms of the rate there's an
increase in the cap that can be paid per
case and the other thing that's
important to know is the expenses
portion that's covered by that line was
something that was new to the judicial
Council in
2021 so that's where we get that request
for the one million dollar budget line
uh if uh there's no further questions
for uh for Casa from async or with
respect to the child protection category
I would move on to the area of indigent
defense
so the Indigent defense account lines
cover four different categories
this fulfills the state's funding of
indigent defense that is mandated by the
federal and state constitutions
and to provide criminal representation
to those who cannot afford it in adult
criminal cases and in juvenile cases
delinquency cases
in New Hampshire we have a three-tiered
system
uh that system consists of in the first
instance appointing the public defender
program
cases the public defender program cannot
accept then go to what are called
contract Council these are lawyers who
have a contract with the judicial
Council who represent people in these
cases on a flat fee basis
when contract counsel is not available
we then go to the third tier which is
assigned Council assigned counsel or
compensated on an hourly basis and like
the other categories we've talked about
here the assigned Council rates have
been increased I'll explain in more
detail in a moment why it was so
important to increase those but I think
the starting point that you should know
is that those rates were the primary
rate it was the first time there's been
an increase in 30 years at the rate the
base rate was set in 1992 at sixty
dollars an hour and now the base rate is
ninety dollars an hour in more serious
cases it's 125 an hour still a
significant reduction from what private
Council would be charging in cases like
this
um the judicial council's priority here
uh in this biennial budget submission is
funding of the public defender program
and we're requesting what would be the
largest increase in the public
defender's history uh over three million
dollars for each year the biennium
to explain the need for that I have to
begin by telling you that the public
defender is the backbone of the Indigent
defense system in a typical year the
public defender program would handle
about 85 percent of the Indigent defense
caseload
historically contract lawyers which is
that second tier would handle about
another 14 percent and then a signed
Council would handle the remaining one
percent
the last three years have been anything
but typical years
and in fiscal year uh 22 the public
defender was only able to handle about
80 percent of that caseload so although
that's only a five percent decrease uh
the ripple effect on the on the system
has been huge uh High staff turnovers at
the public defender K uh office and uh
fewer cases getting resolved during the
pandemic led to a backlog of cases uh an
extremely high case loads when the
governor declared the State of Emergency
on March 13th of 2020
between that moment in time and when the
budget was submitted from this agency
back in the fall the public defender had
49 attorneys resign from their program
that represented not just a percentage
of the lawyers they have there but a
significant percentage of their work
experience it was a total of
443 years of combined work experience
during that same period they've hired
new lawyers 55 new lawyers during that
time period with a combined 123 years of
experience but that's not quite enough
to offset the difference there's a
handout in the materials I provided last
week which shows that sort of
change and experience level
as you can imagine ex new lawyers for
the most part don't enter
with the ability to handle the same
level or same number of cases that their
experienced counterparts have the same
way that a first-year resident at a
hospital probably isn't going to be
doing any brain surgery or heart
transplants the shift in experiences
coincided with increasingly complex
cases and that is part of the basis of
this request as well
the seismic shift in experience level is
also
supplemented or complemented by an
increased need to spend time on cases
increased need for resources for those
cases and the assistance of what has
become the norm in this industry so to
speak of having the assistance of social
workers and paralegals who can assist
with complex cases and electronic
evidence and when I say electronic
evidence I mean not only digital
evidence but video evidence which is
becoming not only more common but almost
commonplace in every one of these cases
evaluating those evidence uh that
evidence and making it into a usable
form and then the Court's expectation
that the public defender will use its
resources to come up with plans for
individuals in terms of treatment plans
at the outset so there is a significant
amount of resources being spent not only
on legal litigation but on
representation in a way that provides
resources to this population so that
courts can act in a way that provides
them Services through the judicial
system
foreign
so I have a quick question on page 15.
I'm just curious in the numbers here uh
it notes that the judicial Council also
anticipates
that the Youth Development Center
criminal prosecutions will generate
significant additional non-counsel costs
over the next biennium yes do you have a
specific dollar amount that you
anticipate or the number of individuals
that are going to seek legal counsel to
defend themselves against charges there
so those charges have been filed those
cases are pending there are 11 different
defendants in those cases 10 pertain
specifically to YDC one to what was
called ydsu
the state the Attorney General's office
has spent close to two million dollars
on Discovery in that case in terms of
organizing Discovery the reason they've
done that is there's about 30 million
pages of discovery
uh it's unprecedented in this case in
this state uh and frankly anywhere so
the the those 30 million pages of
Discovery that's correct always so that
is being organized what has happened is
that the defense Council that are
representing those 11 individuals have
collectively presented a plan to the
court uh in terms of Discovery
management
um there are some numbers the court is
still deciding uh which plan it is going
to authorize but the expectation is that
if it uh accepts the plan that the
defense Council collectively have
proposed it would be uh probably uh
at least two hundred thousand dollars
over the next 18 months which candidly
is far far less than uh I think the
judicial Council anticipated it might be
um but it's it's a concern on the
horizon and then the cost for Council in
those cases is going to be a significant
concern under the assigned Council line
as well
representative Wallner you're welcome to
join us up here I know you're very
familiar with the judicial Council and
Caso especially
representative Hewitt's spot if you want
I think all the documentation you may
representative Griffin has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question are we dealing as far as
the public defender is concerned are we
dealing only with State cases here or or
does it get down to the county level too
so
um uh thank you for the question
um what we're talking about here is
cases that are filed in the circuit
courts of New Hampshire in the Superior
Courts of New Hampshire and at the New
Hampshire Supreme Court so it's all
criminal cases across the state
are that they are prosecuted at the
county level certainly some of those but
it's only state cases no federal cases
or anything like that
not seeing any welcome to continue thank
you um so just to uh complete uh what I
think it's important to know about this
request for the public defender uh this
is going to allow a 10 salary increase
that was put into effect in April to
continue uh that's critical to them
retaining staff and putting them on
parity with what other
prosecutors in the state are making both
at the county level and at the state
level
it will fund also some additional steps
for lawyers in terms of retention so
previously there were only 12 steps that
a lawyer could get to the new leadership
at the public defender's office which
has been very Dynamic and responsive to
trying to solve these problems has put
into place up to 15 Steps with the idea
of retaining some of those experienced
lawyers there would be an additional
five percent salary increase again
necessary to remain competitive compared
to prosecutors positions and other
people who are leaving for the private
sector and it would create eight new I.T
paralegal positions and allow for
similar I.T upgrades to address what I
was explaining before sort of this new
normal in criminal representation of a
high degree of electronic Discovery
video discovery
the ability to manage it at a local
level
so again this funding increase is not
alone going to solve I think the
Indigent defense crisis that we've been
experiencing here but it's difficult to
imagine how we get through it and get to
the other side of it without this
additional funding and the hope is that
this will allow us to restore and
correct sort of the imbalance that's
been in place in the last three years so
again this is not an additional funding
request that is aimed at expanding
services this is a request that is aimed
at maintaining and restoring services to
the place that they were prior to the
pandemic
I have a quick question on the I.T part
are you working with our doit or are
these independent within your Council so
I'm happy to have Sarah Rothman who is
the director of the uh
public defender program answer that but
I would tell you that this is not
through the New Hampshire
doit program
so have you reached out to the
commission to see if he can help you and
maybe cut some of your costs or
uh um I I will defer but I I should just
say that you know I think there would it
would be highly problematic to have the
state of New Hampshire who prosecutes
defendants involved in the management of
Discovery for defendants I think that
would be a conflict
representative Maguire does have a quick
question I believe she wanted to come I
can't answer that question further I I I
definitely agree with with Richard
um that you know that we have to manage
our own Discovery but I will say
um we do work closely with the courts um
on technology issues we're actually in
Communications with the ports
um to actually essentially have our two
Case Management Systems merge together
um so the idea being right now the case
the court sends us essentially physical
paperwork they might send it
electronically but it's essentially
physical paperwork then we take that in
our support staff processes that they
open a case they they calendar events
for their attorneys we are hoping to
actually integrate our systems so that
when the port sends us a case it
actually Auto populates in our own
system
um to save us resources on you know
support staff time but additional
resources so while certainly we do need
to manage our own I.T departments and
manage the storage and organization of
our voluminous Discovery ourselves we
also do look to the courts for ways to
work together and to create efficiencies
so I guess your response led me to
another question how many people are
embedded now in your I.T
so we have an I.T manager and then we
have four IT staff
so you're looking you said eight eight
new
to clarify those are not those are
paralegal positions so they're not I.T
you know they're not just to help us run
our I.T Department they're actually to
work on individual cases there are new
technology tools many of which are are
too expensive for us that are designed
to kind of take electronic Discovery
index it make it searchable the most
expensive Technologies while also
transcribe video so now virtually almost
every case of ours now includes video of
some sort officers are now wearing body
worn cameras there's a lot of
surveillance video most people have you
know ring cameras businesses homes a lot
of security footage there's also a great
deal of cell phone information so they
will take literally all of the data from
somebody's cell phone and just give it
to you essentially in paper form and so
the paralegals are there so they're not
they're not really I.T employees they're
there to work on individual cases and to
organize that Discovery to digest it on
behalf of attorneys so if you're getting
you know 20 30 hours of video in sort of
a run-of-the-mill case
um you know the paralegal can watch that
and the attorney can give them Direction
on what they're looking for in these
videos so these paralegal positions are
really crucial in dealing with this
spike in technology
discovery that we now received we now
receive
um I what by my I had RIT Department
look at the amount of data that we now
store so data in terms of discovery that
we receive from the state that has
increased by uh 566 percent
um in just the last five years so those
paralegal positions are not really just
to deal with the I.T of all of that it's
to process the information to make it
available for the attorney and to work
closely with the attorney as a team to
talk call this voluminous Discovery
could you provide us with like a
organization chart how many people are
in I.T and the paralegal that would be
very helpful and what new positions
would be uh included in your budget
request in that chart yes and I can
clarify we actually don't currently have
any paralegal positions we're looking
if I could just add so page 13 of the
handout is a visual representation of
that increase in Discovery electronic
Discovery the other thing I think it's
probably important for you to know is
the Superior Courts are moving to an
electronic evidence system so you know
the days of watching a lawyer walk up to
a witness with a piece of paper or a
document and say you know can you answer
some questions about this those are
those days are are going away and the
courts have moved to an electronic
system where documents have to be filed
in advance and they have to be referred
to so the need I think that the public
defender has for electronic uh I'm sorry
I.T paralegals is
consistent with the trend in the courts
to work from electronic evidence and to
manage evidence electronically
thank you representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman
um
so this says that this covers 85 percent
of the cases are the other 15 percent in
some other section of this budget so
um
if I wasn't clear before in in the good
old days the public defender uh took 85
percent of the cases
um it has decreased to about 80 percent
but they are um I think under the new
leadership they're experiencing they are
working their way back and things are
moving in the right direction
um the other 15 15 to 20 right right is
handled by contract Council so again in
the good old days they would handle 14
of that other 15 that's not happening
anymore either we've lost about eight of
the uh 34 contract Wars we've we have so
we're trying to lure more people into
the contract system but what it really
means is that last one percent that had
been handled by assigned Council the
hourly rate attorneys they're handling a
much higher percentage of the cases than
they used to and because they're
handling those cases on an hourly basis
and because uh the need to attract
people to take those cases was so dire
the court finally increased the rate and
I have to say I have to thank the
governor and his office for their
support there because otherwise we would
have no lawyers
um but
um so that used to be one percent I
don't know what the current percentage
is but I can tell you it's a lot higher
yeah so yeah so back to the budget so
this 27 million is 85 or possibly 80
right somewhere in there
then the contract ones are they
somewhere else in this budget right so
that is line 1093 uh that would be page
540 of the budget uh it's page nine of
the handout that okay so that's 2.6
million correct and youth say those are
15 or something ideally it would be 14
14 and then there's a one percent
somewhere else right well it's not one
percent but so that's a signed Council
uh that's uh on page 5 for 38 of the
budget
um so uh sort of accelerating to to that
item uh I would tell you that
um we have already had to go back and we
have had approved from uh the governor
and Council and from fiscal uh an
additional 1.6 million dollar request so
that we can pay uh assigned Council for
fiscal year 23 that revised budget is
now uh over three million dollars
and uh like I've said uh in other
categories because the rate change went
into effect at the beginning of October
we haven't necessarily seen the full
manifestation of that new rate
even more so than the other categories
of cases were we've been talking about
uh cases criminal cases billing
typically doesn't occur until the end of
the case in those cases the longevity of
the lifespan of those cases is is a bit
longer so I'm anticipating we're going
to see a big increase there we have seen
steady increases in the amount of
invoices we're paying every month in the
assigned Council category
um and the the truth is that we're also
seeing more assigned Council in what are
more serious cases so there's a slightly
higher rate there but if we're talking
uh about homicides or sexual assault
cases uh or the YDC cases
um you know those are cases that are
taking an extensive amount of time and
if we have to assign counsel to those
cases we're paying a lot of money to
those lawyers to provide the
representation in those cases the last
thing I would just add about that is you
know I've attached to the handout that I
provided to you in some articles news
articles that addressed
uh sort of a crisis uh at its height and
the involvement of the Supreme Court
um you know I I need to thank the Chief
Justice and all the judges on the court
for creating a task force on Indigent
defense but I mean that is the sort of
the state that we got to that the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court had to go
and make calls to individual lawyers to
ask them to take cases because things
were were that bad
mayor father yeah so
just in general
are the are the public defenders cases
roughly equivalent in terms of
difficulty on average to the contract
Council cases to the assigned Council
cases are not quite oh I think they are
the most difficult of the cases I mean
they have the the they are handling the
bulk of the homicides they are handling
the vast majority of the aggravated
sexual assault cases they have the staff
who does that the the problem is if you
have a co-defendants in a case they can
only take one of those cases if they
have a conflict of interest professional
conflict of interest we have to find
someone else to take that case
and if they can't take cases because
they're senior lawyers instead of having
70 cases which is already a high number
have 90 or 100 cases then we have to go
and find other lawyers to take those
cases so what the hope is over the next
biennium is we can move from sort of
this crisis to and to full Staffing at
the public defender that they can work
back to that 85 percent and that the
need for assigned cases it's assigned
Council cases will drop again but that
is not going to happen tomorrow and
um you know if I'm being realistic about
it I think it's going to take the best
the majority of the biennium to work
through it so what's the difference
what's a contract person I mean but both
of them are full-time yes but they're
but they're no so nope so the public
defender
has a full-time staff they yes work for
the public defender they only work
they're paid salary yes okay contract
Council are lawyers who have their own
offices who take a contract with the
judicial Council to provide legal
services and they agree to take we
designate cases by units they they take
X number of units per year uh when they
reach their unit Mark we can ask them to
take more cases they don't have to agree
to do that they've exceeded their
contract at that point the other
difference is they can refuse cases they
don't have to take a case if they don't
want to but those are contract lawyers
who have other practices as well and
they're paid on a flat fee basis per
case
that third tier the assigned Council
they're not in either of those category
they're again in lawyers working in
their own offices who on occasion are
agreeable to taking representation and
providing representation in cases and so
again we're
literally calling people every day
asking them to take cases so the public
defender has a conflict case
administrator they make those calls but
I can tell you on Tuesday I called three
lawyers asking them to take cases
probably not what the head of an agency
should spend a lot of time doing but
that's sort of what what is the current
situation
if you don't mind if I can add just a
few thoughts to your thank you last few
questions
um so the vast majority of cases that go
on to either contract Council or
assigned Council are because of a
conflict of interest as Richard just
indicated so those are cases because of
the rules of professional conduct we
just cannot accept curious as of the
cases and as Richard indicated
um you know aside from conflict there is
some that we sometimes have to send out
cases because we just don't have the
Staffing in order to do it but as
Richard indicated that tide is turning
um and we are back
um you know back to keeping
um you know still sending out conflict
cases cases we just are not allowed to
represent but back to keeping um you
know the majority of those cases and
we've drastically reduced just sending
out cases because we can't we can't
handle them okay man so units
is is it like a car theft case is three
units and a a homicide is 25 units or
something like that is is that how it
works yeah that's a that's a way to
think about it so homicide cases really
aren't units they're sort of a unique
category okay but um yeah felony cases
uh most felony cases are valued at a
certain number of units misdemeanor
cases are valued at a certain number of
units then there's a what's called a
felony one category which is a
serious felony category that gets a
higher number of units but that is how
it works okay so a contract attorney
agrees to take this car theft case
for a certain dollar amount right
regardless of whether it gets appealed
or whatever right however you know it
could be over within a day or it could
take three weeks or something right
you're you're correct
um except for the appeal part that would
be a separate uh maybe a new case or a
new something I see okay thank you can
we get some numbers in terms of so many
cases of
that are district court cases so many
other Superior Court cases so many that
are Supreme Court cases maybe or
um
the public defender does this many cases
and the contract is that because on
paper it looks to me like the contract
people are the best value
compared to the other two categories so
um so I unfortunately have two answers
for your question but I appreciate you
asking uh because it sort of highlights
something that's very important uh the
judicial branch keeps statistics on case
filings of Superior Court filing circuit
court filings and they keep statistics
on a calendar year basis the judicial
Council which is three people does not
have staff to keep statistics on
the variety of things that I would love
to give you information about but don't
have those specific numbers so in terms
of case filings I could tell you you can
go to the judicial branch website and
it's actually posted the number of
felonies and misdemeanors that are filed
on a given calendar year in terms of uh
the cases that the public defender is
taking
um
the
I can tell you
um
the number of cases that they've taken I
know that yeah but I can't uh but
because the judicial branch tracks
filings for misdemeanors and felonies
but doesn't separately
include juvenile cases and then
separately accounts appeal cases my
estimations of the 80 and 85 percent
that is a to be very clear that is a
best guess but
um and I think it's an accurate guess
but uh it's not uh Based on data that is
available to me through the judicial
branch
so yeah so I know that that there are 17
000 circuit court cases or something
like that a year but how many are
Indigent right so that's what I don't
know
um so
um
uh you know I don't think uh attorney
Rothman can answer that but I and I but
she's I'm happy to have her try but I
would tell you that uh anecdotally as
someone who's practiced in that system
for close to 30 years I would say the
you know it's got to be at least
80 to 90 percent of the cases are
Indigent cases I see in all levels yeah
okay yes the Superior Court Etc yes
and what fraction are criminal versus I
could ask the Judiciary right criminal
versus civil yeah yes and I I don't have
that information and we don't fund those
cases you're not funding Indigent civil
well we talked about legal assistance
yes last week but other than that we're
not funding so much all right thank you
so you've been very generous with your
time I don't want to uh prolong it
unless you have more questions I just
want to touch on two more things quickly
if I could but just a question on a
number of people you just referenced you
had three people working in the office
and I thought I heard you say earlier
that you were hoping to hire the
so-called I.T paralegal people but I see
in the budget it still only carries
three people those contract workers that
you hope to hire I apologize I was not
clear the judicial Council the agency
we're an agency of three people the
public defender's budget is requesting
for their organization okay
okay we will yeah hundreds yeah
thanks
so the I think I have in response to
your questions
um gone over most of the points I wanted
to address with respect to the three
levels of council the last category of
expense which is 1103 and on page 541 of
the budget talks about what are called
ancillary non-council Services those are
Services other than lawyers that are
provided in cases where a judge makes
the determination that the expense is
necessary for uh representation in that
case so when we were talking before
about sort of managing Discovery in the
YDC cases it would fall under this
category of expense these are expenses
that typically include interpreters
preparing transcripts
evaluations for substance abuse and
other mental health evaluations again
that's just for the Court's use in
determining how to respond to cases it's
not a treatment an ongoing expense
uh and that is this an area where we've
again also had to go back and ask for
additional funding there was 1.5 million
dollars
further appropriated and the revised
budget there is 2.6 million currently
which is on par with what our request is
for the next biennial
the last uh thing I'd like to just
address very quickly or just some quick
observations I've made as a acting
director who's coming in to this agency
I've only been here
uh two and a half months and I'm coming
from the private sector but I will tell
you that although my predecessor did not
request any sort of additional Staffing
for this agency it strikes me that this
is an agency in the next biennium that
really should ask for additional
Staffing the people there work very hard
I think that they are
up to facing a lot of challenges going
forward but I think the absence of a
request for Staffing there really
highlights my predecessors
prioritization of indigent defense and
the other budget requests we're making
over the needs of the agency and I think
it just speaks a lot to our budget
request into the importance of providing
those funds to
people that the agency serves not to the
agency itself
um they're the one other thing there was
uh in the original budget request a
request for a funding for a second
public defender program uh that's not
part of the governor's request and we
certainly respect that
um but in terms of some of the questions
you've asked today about how we get
through this uh funding crisis and how
we get back to sort of the area we want
to be in terms of distribution of who's
handling these cases the thought would
be that creation of a program like that
whether it's in this biennium or in the
future might be the the best way to
yes if you could come up and take the
congratulations
I should my name is Nina Gardner for
those of you who don't know me I was the
executive director of the judicial
Council for 24 years and I retired 11
years ago and I'm still here because I
care very much I'm still chairman of the
judicial Council because I care very
much about what the judicial Council
does and what it provides to citizens of
our state that need the representation I
am not a lawyer I'm not married to a
lawyer I'm you know I I learned this
work doing it but I have to tell you is
that where we are now is unprecedentedly
challenging it is part of why I think uh
Richard's predecessor departed what we
are being asked to do to solve the
problem of a limited Workforce underpaid
people challenging clients who have
mental health issues substance abuse
issues
um the pandemic to deal with has been
unprecedented and created the system or
situ situation we're in now what I have
to say to you is if you do not
appropriate what the governor has
proposed we will not go forward we will
slide backward and our goal is to try to
get back would you just said it over and
over again to the equilibrium we know in
new but it is a very challenging
changing environment just the role of
electronics which I would like to have
other people really understand and I
think some of you do
um that with that electronic and um
input of information it just changes the
nature of how this work is done making
it more complicated take making things
take longer so please see that's where
we are and the only way forward is with
your support of an appropriation that
gives us the tools to go for it these
cases will exist whether or not you pay
for them but you ultimately pay for them
one way or the other you pay for them
either in the most expensive way or in a
more appropriate way and and just to say
one more thing contract Council which
has always been a very cost effective
way to do the work we can't attract
people to do it because the fixed fee
rates are so low they get no overhead
they have no benefits and these clients
are tough to deal with so that which we
used for all those years the governor
sununu the first built with the judicial
Council in 1985 doesn't work very well
anymore and our goal is to get beyond
that in many ways to have two pillars
that are more predictable
lots of contract attorneys with me for
all the time I was here but they've left
because we don't pay them enough so I
implore you to understand that the
budget that you have in front of you
that the governor has provided is is the
footprint forward
um is a minimum of what we need to have
to work uh to get through this to the
next biennium
and I do want to also say just in in in
really recognizing how fortunate we were
to get Richard to step in
um losing our former executive director
was heartbreaking to me but when you
realize part of what she was doing every
day was begging people to take cases
um it's just emotionally exhausting and
I'm so appreciative for what she did
Richard is stepping in from his private
practice to do this
um and so I again just want to say the
appropriation is is vital to the agency
you've all become friends in my life I
guess representative McGuire has a
question yeah actually too but
um you mentioned contract counsel so
does this budget include higher rates
for them or no I don't see it on this
page it doesn't specifically include
that I mean certainly our hope that we
can offer them more we have in the past
biennium uh offered some additional
funding to take on cases uh for people
who are incarcerated and some
administrative costs but it's really a
token cost I I can tell you that I spent
11 years as a public defender then I
went into private practice when I did so
uh Nina was kind enough to give me a
contract and I took it and was happy to
have that monthly income coming in but
as soon as I was able I got rid of the
contract because it's not cost effective
to run a business uh with the contract
and that's the problem we see is that
the people who
um are successful lawyers are abandoned
the contract because it's it's just not
financially it doesn't make sense to run
a business that way and I just want to
comment the other piece of the contract
program
incentive
the time into these k cases that is
necessary if we give you a flat fee what
is a misdemeanor these days Richard it's
350. we pay 75 375 a lawyer gets paid
375 dollars to take on a misdemeanor
case if you go to court several times
three or four times you've eaten it they
don't get mileage they they just it's
it's flat fee and for young lawyers
starting out a while ago 1985 that was
probably a good deal the problem is it's
not a good deal anymore and so we are
trying to find a way
um to morph out of that system
um because it's the disincentive to do
the a good amount of work that's
necessary is really problematic a lot of
states have given up contract programs
because
as well as the money
so are you saying you'd find it easier
to hire more for the public defender's
office than to find more contract people
well I I think in
first of all the contract uh Council
versus public defender it's not
it's not the right comparison in the
sense that the public defender is going
to have some conflict cases like they
will never be able to handle 100 sure so
it's got to go somewhere and right now
that's the contract lawyer program but
you know if you asked me
um
is that the the best way to do it is
that do I see it in 10 years as uh still
being here as the effective method I I
don't I mean it's just not going to be
the way we move forward on those cases
and and ideally there would be an
alternative public defender program that
would take those conflict cases and
there would be a very small amount of
assigned Council cases
yeah I mean there's no reason you
couldn't have public defender firm
number one and public defender firm
number two right I mean absolutely and
that is what the requests that we had in
the governor's budget was about was to
create this alternative program so that
we could morph away from the contract
program
um and there's a corridor um in New
Hampshire where the bulk of the cases
are that is where we can probably try to
do an alternative public defender you
wouldn't try to do get it to go all the
way up north
um because it's the number of cases up
there are so much smaller it's best
served with individual attorneys but
that is where we're trying to head so I
I sense that you you understand where we
think we are which is number one in
crisis and the key out of this place is
with the appropriation from the
governor's budget as much as you can do
that all right
okay this is the big picture question so
the the population of our prisons is
declining the the population of New
Hampshire is aging is the amount of
crime and therefore the amount of work
for this office declining
so
um case filings uh definitely are
trending downward uh but in terms of
your prison population question I mean I
would give a lot of credit to the
lawyers who handle the cases now this
now provide and the court system the
judicial branch for creating
alternatives to incarceration for people
that that may not need it not to say we
don't need prisons there are certainly
people that that need to be there but
um there's a lot of more thought that
has been given to alternatives to that
but to answer your question uh I I think
it depends where case trends go in the
next five years and if the
arrests go up then the need for Council
is going to go up
um and if it goes down if crime
decreases arrests decrease well then I
think we'll be in a better position to
address all of those needs I I did not
mention to you and I
omitted that there's been a there's a
hold list for the first time in history
cases that are not yet assigned to
anyone in those three categories and at
one point it was a thousand cases back
in August and since the new
Administration has come into the public
defender uh it's now to about 600 and
you know that's a lot of people but that
is a significant Improvement and so once
we get through those 600 I then I'll be
happy to come back and answer your
question again
and I should mention never in my 24
years
four years available to be assigned and
it speaks to the kind of the factors the
cost now I also want to make a clear
lots of folks are not going to law
school these days the practice of law is
not as appealing as it once was I think
it's all in technology uh you know I
think a lot of things have changed so
significantly that this issue that we're
facing is Nationwide public defender
programs around the country are facing
similar challenges and so you know we
are one of many
um experiencing this all we care about
is here
with you and
so thank you for letting me speak
representative pleasure well thank you
but I I did have a question I don't want
to become like representative McGuire my
dear friend to the left of me here but
I'm curious why you didn't include any
increase in the rate under the public
defenders program for Contract Services
I think you mentioned 350 dollars for Mr
Mina charge the attorney gets I see it's
gone up substantially but you said that
you hadn't built in like a cost increase
for a contract so I I think what you're
referring to is the account line for
contract Council so not the public
defender but uh there is a an increase
there and I think it's our hope one is
to be able to
continue with some of the incentives
we've provided to take the cases of that
are people who are incarcerated that
they're less willing to take normally
and some of the administrative costs but
yes if the appropriation is goes through
I think that puts us in a position when
we redo the contract to be able to offer
a better rate and maybe attract more
people to that thanks
I think without it the contract system
is going to just continue to sort of
Wither on the vine but we have not
specifically put money in the budget to
cover that okay
which means you've got to give us what
we've asked for
well some of us are still afraid of you
so you're upgraded me I'm just glad all
everywhere
thank you both appreciate your uh
attention to our needs so thanks bench
again we won't make a decision on this
budget today we're still waiting for
Revenue numbers and of course yours is
under scrutiny because all of your money
comes from General funds so right we'll
have paid close attention and we'll let
you know if we need to have you come
back thank you thank you thank you Mr
sorry so so we're about to get into
bills now we have we have 19 bills that
we're going to consider over the next
two days and so I went and read them and
made a little summary sheet for you and
and the notes on the side are my
personal notes about these bills your
mileage may vary of course so
foreign
um
you know we appreciate your efforts
so next on our
agenda today we have House Bill 571
relative
to the cost of living adjustment for a
certain group two retirees in the New
Hampshire Retirement System
let's see do we have any
body would like to offer any quick and I
say quick commentary and sure sure and
if you could please state your name for
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I hope this is quick I did
time it it's about six minutes is that
quick enough sure okay I'm sorry Alpha
my name is Arthur Beaudry
it's spelled b-e-a-u-d-i-y
and I'm the president of the New
Hampshire State permanent firefighters
retirement Association I am a retired
captain from the Manchester fire
department and they passed Trustee of
the New Hampshire retirement system for
13 years I'm here today in support of
House Bill 571 which would Grant a cola
to retirees who have been retired for
over 10 years to 20 years for those of
you who may not know the history of
granting colas his little background
prior to the establishment of the
special account in 1983 to fund cost of
living adjustments the cost of living
Cola was granted by the legislature and
funded through the general fund from
1967 to 1983.
from 1983 to 2012 annual colas were
granted based on the availability to
fund them through the special account
the Kohler amount range from one percent
to five percent based on the cpiu and
funds available in the members members
group account from 2007 in 2007 House
Bill 6353 changed the funding trigger
as of June 30th 2007 of the for the
special account and retained 204 million
dollars in the Corpus of the fund that
would have gone to the special account
in 2008 House Bill 1645 transferred 250
million dollars from the special account
to the Corpus of the fund in 2011 House
Bill 2 transferred 167 million dollars
from the special account to the Corpus
of the fund and in 2012 House Bill 1483
eliminated the language for special
account and the remaining 16 million
dollars was transferred from the special
account to the Corpus of the fund
the elimination of the special account
and the transfer of 637 million dollars
from the special account to the Corpus
of the fund has precluded any future
colas from being granted to the New
Hampshire retirement system retirees
unless enabling legislation is enacted
retired retirees have received one Cola
since 2010. it was a one and a half
percent cost of living increase based on
the members retirement kept at fifty
thousand dollars
over the last decade the cost of living
based on the cpiu has gone up
29.33 percent while coal is granted to
group two police and fire over the same
time period was one one and a half
percent
over the last 20 years the cost of
living has gone up by 64.53 percent
while coal is granted to group two
police and firefighters over the same
time period with 12.25 and 15
respectively
that is over 52 percent of a pensioner's
buying power that has been eliminated
due to inflation and the lack of
adequate colas last year the 500 stipend
went predominantly to group one out of
the 11.6 million dollars fiscal note
group one received 10.75 million dollars
over 92 percent of the 11.6 million
dollars went to group one
of that 2000 23 267 eligible recipients
there were only 498 group 2 firefighters
receiving the stipend last year we were
told that uh by this committee that it
wasn't a budget year and to come back
this year and a cola could be
implemented in the budget social
security has given its members an 8.7
percent increase this year unfortunately
group two police and firefighters don't
receive Social Security under the
windfall Act of 1984 if a group two
member were to be eligible for Social
Security their benefits would be reduced
by 40 at minimum and as much as 90
percent depending on their pension
predominantly New Hampshire retirement
system is what group two members rely on
for their retirement income very simple
math will show that the matter of time
without color adjustments pensions will
be forced on some kind of Social
Services because their pensions will be
devoured by inflation
the average pension of group 2 police
and firefighters is thirty eight
thousand one hundred and ninety two
dollars and forty two thousand nine
hundred and forty eight dollars
respectively
there's a report developed by nasra on
the cost of the living adjustments that
show how inflation impacts the
purchasing power on a twenty five
thousand dollar pension Falls to sixteen
thousand six ninety uh dollars sixty
seven percent of its original value over
a 20-year period with no cost of living
adjustments based on a two percent
inflation Factor the natural brief also
shows that New Hampshire is an anomaly
Most states provide this retirees with a
cost of living adjustment the state of
Maine for example who came to testify at
the request of this decennial committee
they offer a three percent cholera to
their retirees Massachusetts offers an
ad hoc Cola based on the cpiu of 5
applied to the first thirteen thousand
dollars of benefits Vermont offers an
automatic Cola based on the cpiu to up
to five percent compounded
over the last several years the
legislature has arbitrarily taken funds
away from the retired workers that would
have been paid paying for colas and
Health Care subsidies by changing dates
and when excessive earnings were
reported and the elimination of the
special accounts some 637 million
dollars dedicated to retirees was
diverted for no justifiable reason other
than to lower the employer's
contributions on the backs of the
retirees granting a reasonable colon for
group two retirees will greatly reduce
the impact inflation has incurred on
them over the last two decades I ask
that you please support your retired
Public Safety workers and vote in favor
of House Bill 571 and those desperately
needed cost of living adjustments and I
will answer any questions
could you also provide a copy of your
testimony to our LBA folks you can have
well seeing none uh just to let you know
where we stand we are still waiting for
Revenue estimates I believe you're
uh the bill that you're supporting is
about an 84 million dollar impact on our
general funds which is pretty
substantial as you can well imagine
right so we haven't made any decisions
and we probably won't until we get the
revenue estimates
um
I think that's it we'll get a copy of
your testimony and Marty do you have
anything to add back there if you had
any questions for me but I don't have
anything else to pretend okay I just
can't stress enough that group two
um has not received adequate colas over
the last 20 years and we don't receive
Social Security
um so that those are the two big factors
that I hope you look at when when you're
looking at this bill
so maybe you said it in your testimony
what's the average uh pension that group
two members are getting now it's 38 000
something for police and forty two
thousand something for fire okay it's
pretty close I think Social Security the
max is about 43 000 a year so it's in
that same okay that's why last year's uh
stipend didn't affect group two because
you based it on people that made less
than thirty thousand right and it didn't
didn't affect us on I think two percent
of all that money went to group two all
the rest was that went to group one
uh representative Griffin has a question
do they say no you don't good question
for Marty yeah Marty thank you very much
thank you very much
Marty if you don't mind coming forward
and
always
represent Maguire as a question for you
thank you so
um pensions have upper limits
um some for some people it's different
for different people but it's either 85
percent or 100 percent of their final
salary
um so my question is
is is uh House Bill 571
um
do does the upper limit count or or is
this a extra beyond the up those upper
limits in some cases the
um objective for the record uh Marty
Carlin from nhrs
um the the bill affects
um folks who are retired either 10 uh 10
to 19 years ago or more than 20 years
ago the the maximum benefit limit in the
statute uh was enacted in 09 for anyone
who commends service after 09 so this
Cola does those maximum limits wouldn't
apply to any of these retirees because
because they start because of their
entry date in the system
um that said it is a five or ten percent
Cola on the first 50 000 of their
benefits so if their benefit is in
excess of that it wouldn't you know
there's a maximum amount of what the
what the cola would be because it's on
I representative Weiler
thank you Mr chairman Mr Carlin my
recollection over three decades has been
that cost of living adjustments have
been few and far between I don't think
it's on anybody could call it a regular
thing
I think there was only in the 90s when
we had a pretty good Surplus that I
remember them being fairly consistent
but I don't think they have been prior
to that or even since is that likely
there I think it had been through the
2000s they were a fairly fairly
consistent they were um whatever the
number ended up being I think fiscal
committee was the one who said it and it
was based on how much funding was in the
special account which Mr Beaudry
referred to him which was repealed
um back in 2011 or 12. um I don't have
it with me but I will send
um the LBA folks to share I I look on
our website we have a history of coal is
going back to the late 90s so you can
just just for reference
um you know but you know and but he's
absolutely correct in saying that the
last prior to 2010 which was sort of a
legacy from a 2008 Bill the only Cola
was not enacted in 19 and took effect in
20.
yeah before then I I doesn't go back as
far but I I do looking at sort of the
you know the ledges the bound volumes of
the legislation over years it seems like
it was very ad hoc back in the 70s and
80s as well like the the special account
was as you know
it it'll effects that it had that was
that was a way to try to set up a fund
thank you thank you
representative McGuire thank you
um have group one employees ever had
colas
the the last oh so and to my historical
record which you know predates when I
started but goes back to the 90s when
colors were granted every group got them
sometimes the percentages were different
among the groups a lot of most years
they were the same the 2019 Cola bill
um I think I forget the bill number but
that was the one and a half for all
across the board
all right so when you make a historical
chart maybe have a group one yeah
back at the office that I should have
brought has them broken down in columns
thank you very much that would be
helpful Marty thanks uh representative
uh Weiler
who knows why
remembering when we were doing these uh
cost of living adjustments
one of the things we looked at was how
much Surplus there was now when person
is hired they contribute to the
retirement and so does the employer if
the person leaves before they're vested
they get to take what they put in but
the money the employer put in stays
there
so if you have a lot of turnover I.E
teachers there's more money in that fund
there's less turnover in the firemen
than any any other group the police had
had a higher turnover than the firemen
and the teachers and the employees
certainly had a higher so when we looked
at the amounts of money
where we could give a cost of living
and one of my colleagues who was a
fireman was saying
those people hate the firemen
and it was all because there was less
Surplus in the Fireman's Fund because
not only were there fewer firemen but
there were fewer who left money in the
fund most of them stayed there the 20
years thank you for the Loyalty but as
far as there was far more turnover in
the other groups which left more money
so sometimes it ended up with the
teachers getting twice as much as the
firemen just due to the fact there was
more money in the fund so it didn't have
anything to do with with the Prejudice
and unfortunately the Loyalty of the
firemen costs them that that cost of
living adjustment so that was something
that we regretted but that was the money
I'm just going through the testimony I
thought I could find it I thought it was
said but when is the last time group two
received any sort of cola they were all
group two in group one all were in the I
think it was hb616 it was enacted in
2019 and took took effect in fiscal 20.
um that was the 500 no no that was oh
the
um the the cola was in 2019 begin taking
effect in 20 there was a 500 temporary
supplement allowance a one-time payment
this past year it's a voter referred to
and because the the recipients were
capped at thirty thousand dollars or
less annually fewer firefighters there's
a percentage of that group received the
500 then you know other groups because
their formulas generate larger benefits
because of the Social Security
them not being in Social Security
okay
seeing no further questions thanks Marty
uh the division have any thoughts on
this uh
information
we'll hold on to it then yeah I think
um I didn't know if you were thinking of
amendment uh Professor McGuire well yeah
I mean so certainly I would think this
bill should be retained and if we're
going to do anything in this area it
would go into the budget
um
now in specifically I put the word taper
here one of my least favorite parts of
this bill is
that it's it's got two chunks in it
right so so somebody who retired one day
could get half the benefit of somebody
who retired the day previously right so
that that to me is unattractive and so
one thing we could do is make it
year by year by year or something like
that as a as a more of a ramp rather
than as a as two steps
um the other thing according to Carol is
that frequently cola's this bill is a
cola that is permanent for the rest of
the person's life whereas frequently
colas are given more as for the next two
years a certain amount and that would
make a big difference in the in the cost
of this bill
so when you mention classes you have the
taper the one time or itl so what do you
what's your lead out of those three
I think we can't make that decision
until we know how much money we have to
spend and
put it in the pile with all the other
things all right we agree I was told
yesterday we might know something today
good idea that's going to depend on
everything we do today thanks so much
thanks Mike
so we'll take a three minute break I
mean some of the smaller bills we can
yeah maybe oh no problem
all right we'll uh open the work session
on House Bill 74.
and this is relative to an employee's
unused earned time I do see
representative Cahill here like to give
be careful you know we might get one so
it's not a public hearing it's at work
uh good morning I as Mr Lee Smith
alluded to I am representative Michael
Cahill from uh Newmarket I represent the
town the new market and new fields in
Rockingham 10. and I'm pleased that
you're here working on this bill we we
did a good job with it in the house last
week
and uh let me tell you a little bit
about uh I don't I don't see Mr
arlinghaus here but he testified in
labor that the fiscal impacts despite
the rather horrendous four and a half
million in the fiscal note uh as far as
the state's concerned it would be his
word de Minimus
and that's because people aren't likely
to leave on Mass
uh and and or take you know large
amounts of accrued time with them so as
far as the state's concerned no no real
no real impact I think in the
municipalities
uh though I am not now nor have I ever
been a member of a union I think many
many in those areas are members of
unions and I assume that the current CBA
would hold
for the life of that agreement
and and going further going forward that
this issue would not need to be
negotiated because
everyone would be able to take their
unused vacation time with them
under you know at least if they were
left in good standing I don't or laid
off
I don't think we're selling towns just
yet so we wouldn't be the business is
sold as another another consideration
for when the when the person uh takes
their uh vacation time with them and
also uh this only applies to uh
businesses entities with 15 or more
employees and I suppose there could be
some unincorporated areas small towns
that really just have two or three
people they would be they wouldn't be
subject to this although I have to I
have to say that I think this is
actually the right thing to do that that
you earn your vacation time it's like
wages and so that when you leave you
know uh you should be you should receive
those wages in your final paycheck
provided that you're not being fired for
cause or or
that's that's basically it other states
I know we're not other states but other
states have laws protecting the employer
the employee regardless of the
circumstances of their departure but
that's not what this does
and
so again I think there's nothing in here
about uh prohibiting an employer from uh
having a user to lose it uh during you
know for the for the calendar year you
have this much time if you don't use it
within that period it's gone they could
they could still do that which would
discourage people from accumulating a
great mass of time and then retiring and
well now you all meet you know three
thousand dollars a month you know we
don't want that so that that's not
that's not any part of this bill it
really just uh says that if you are
employed uh if there are 15 or more
employees and the and the employer
offers paid leave and not everyone does
uh then it would be yours in the you
know if upon termination provided that
you leave on good terms or in the event
that the uh you're laid off
which of course you don't get advance
notice of that and um and the business
is is sold which one might expect as I
as I said last week that when you when
the business is sold you either receive
your vacation pay or the the amount is
transferred to the next to the new owner
which is the decent thing to do but
that's not the current lot that you
don't have to do that you may do it but
I really think we should be meeting
people's reasonable expectations and
passing this law
foreign
committee report on both sides so I see
there's concern and support so obviously
that's why there was a 10-10 vote
now I as you know the finance committee
we try to stay focused to the fiscal
impact but I'm looking at the fiscal
note
and it's showing
up to perhaps a 4.5 million
yes uh as I as I said that was from from
the uh Department of administrative
Services Mr arlinghaus said that uh in
truth it is the impact would be de
minimis
representative Wiley has a question
not clear reading the bill
so this is applying to private
contractors and maybe even cities towns
and counties
yes all the above so it could be a 28a
issue
to some degree it's small but it could
be a 28 day issue very very very modest
I I think I I would think we are that we
are probably in the in the public sector
we're probably doing better in terms of
taking good care of people throughout
their employee
and especially now it's very hard for
people to to hire and retain
and the last thing you want is a bad
reputation out there in the community
that well I left and they you know they
didn't pay me my two weeks that I had
earned and didn't get to use
and hopefully follow up with
um people coming to locate their
businesses in this state this would not
be something that would turn them away
whereas if we put too many restrictions
on on how they treat their employees
they might go elsewhere I understand and
I and I do believe that this this should
not be a deal breaker for someone
committing you know considering New
Hampshire
represent Gambrills thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking the question
um how widespread do you think this is
because I know when I worked in uh in
the public sector almost all the
companies uh reimburse you for vacation
whenever you retired left were laid off
so how how widespread do you think this
is is it an issue uh thank you for the
question uh the department of New
Hampshire Department of Labor has said
that roughly 20 percent of of wage
claims involve vacation pay
you know someone someone said someone
someone doesn't get what they think they
have coming to them they go to the
department those that you know they have
many phone calls and when they when they
say to them that well I don't I what's
the policy if the policy has this
disclaimer that says we don't pay upon
termination then that often discourages
people from going forward with a hearing
uh some still do and they hit that they
hit this stone wall they said uh there
is a
an assisted living center located in my
town and the owner sold the company the
people continued on the same employment
with the new employer and their vacation
day disappeared it was gone because he
said the pawn termination wait don't pay
vacation
uh there was another incident uh someone
I happened to work with in a couple of
different situations she worked for this
company as a shipper for seven years she
had a couple of weeks of vacation pay
they called her in Friday and today is
your last day and she did go to the
department but and they the employer
responded and explained that well we we
didn't give her her vacation hours
because our company policy requires that
you request the time three weeks in
advance
and being laid off with no notice left
her no opportunity to request it through
extend that so it does happen and as the
department said twenty percent of the
time twenty percent of their complaints
involved this at least is one of the
factors so I think it's something we
need to address
further question
thank you Mr chair so 20 do you have the
number of so what is 20 of what
uh I I'm sorry I I don't have that with
me I will get it to you but I do have I
did have some documents from previous
iterations of the bill how many claims
there were this year in that year and
how many involved that but I will get
kind of a follow-up to representative
Weiler's questions
what if the what was the position of the
Department of Labor on this proposed
legislation I I think you know that our
state agencies tend to remain neutral at
least but some of them but I will tell
you that in in my interactions uh with
the Department this is something that
they believe is should be done it's the
right thing to do and I think uh some of
their hearing officers are probably
frustrated
with some of these hearings that they
can't rule on behalf of the person who
was obviously shortchanged
represent Maguire thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative
um did it come up in you I'm trying to
think of how this could possibly relate
to the budget right so did it come up as
to
we have certain what we call
anti-spiking
um things in our laws that prevent
um
vacation pay and other special pay at
the end of one's service from Counting
as extra income for the last year so for
the purpose of boosting a retirement
payment would this bill make any changes
in that area or affected at all no oh
thank you for the question Mr Maguire no
I no I don't believe it would
inasmuch as there is nothing to prevent
the employer from limiting you know
saying if you don't use it by this time
you lose it
uh and I I I don't see this as a as a
spiking enabling bill
yeah I don't mean
um for private employers I meant for
state employees
would it would we have to change
something else somewhere
dealing with state employees as a result
of this do you see what I mean I don't
believe so I'll give it not to my
knowledge yeah
um all right thank you yeah represent
evil thank you thank you for being here
do you know if New Hampshire is unusual
and not having a provision that requires
unearned time to be paid I would say
we're we are not unusual we're not in
the minority the things do vary but uh I
believe right now there are probably
only seven or eight states that address
this and some to a harsher degree than
others like I said in Massachusetts and
in Maine recently doesn't matter you
could punch the boss in the nose and
they still have to pay you the vacation
pay so we're not trying to do that here
in New Hampshire so you don't need to
get a face guard or anything and go back
or then uh I've had numerous
conversations with Mr Juve
and interestingly you know he he has a
concern that you know if any time you
tell a business how to run their
business that that gets his dander up
yet this the examples I cited he agreed
those were in his word egregious and
shouldn't be allowed to happen
so somehow we have to find a way to stop
those from happening while not taking
away everything that a business you know
can do or design with its benefits I I
think this bill does that we're not
requiring employers to offer paid time
off we are
using the the number 15 as a threshold
which I guess is used in other
situations
and and it's uh
it doesn't touch the annual user lose it
it only refers to what happens
when Trump when employment ends and
under really either two circumstances
that are beyond the employee's control
and the other one leaving in good
standing is really to the benefit of
both the employer and the employee
and I and again I think uh people aren't
leaving in droves so I I think the
impact the fiscal impacts even for a
business would be small and basically
the right thing to do
yeah
so is this a topic that's covered in
Union contracts
I I I think it may be and and again I
assume that any current
contract would remain in force and that
in the future that this topic might not
representative hatch has a question for
you
um
all full-time employees uh get paid time
off
um at one time I was a full-time
employee but I worked on a straight
commission basis
and I dictated my hours I dictated where
and when I went
um and dictated
how I went about doing my business you
might have been a 1099
no no but the prerequisite they dictated
whom I had as a client so that was the
thing that changed that so how is this
handled for those individuals same way
or
um because I I had a contract and and I
really didn't have any vacation time but
that was my choice and like another goal
as I chose so to speak so word is that
tie in that's one question
I can't wait for the next one thank you
Mr Heads uh
uh boy uh as it's been pointed out it is
difficult to cover every possible
scenario in which people work I think
that since you had agreed not to have
vacation then they wouldn't owe you
anything
if a similar person working under the
same terms
uh that said if you if your time was
your own to use as your own
that's certainly uh that's something
that you agreed to and I don't think
this would be prohibited it provided the
representative Griffin
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
the question I'm interested to go back
to that case that was brought to the
labor department you said that
the company's position was that
she had the employee had to give three
weeks notice yet she was terminated so
she didn't have the ability so how did
the label Department find on that
particular case
uh in that particular case when the when
the claimant the employee received the
response from the employer I she I think
she just gave up because that's the
policy said no you don't get it and that
was the end of it and that's one of the
that's this is how I got interested in
this issue I ran into her in the
supermarket as you know we often do with
people and and she told me about it and
you know it was later that they learned
about the incident and with the Assisted
Living place so this is just one of
those things that we shouldn't allow
people to do
as as of as a follow-up um
it really concerns me that this this
Bill gets involved in that in the
business of the business so people have
to do a certain amount of accounting and
this and that and I'm not sure that the
abuses that may exist
warrant that all
and I'm just concerned it's more
bureaucracy
it's more work for
particularly 15 employees is not a big
company
they might only have one person that
takes care of the office and it's just
another level of of more work and I'm
not sure it's justified by the abuses
that exist
uh Mr Griffin I I think uh as as I
recall the uh
Mr Juve of the Bia felt that the
record-keeping was really just good
business practice
and I would say that if uh if it was you
or someone that you knew who was on the
receiving end or they started
non-receiving end of this you might view
that that issue differently
uh that is to say that you know 20 like
I remember someone in the previous
hearing saying well 20 that's not much
20 is a lot 20 is a 20 pay raise 20 tax
increase
20 you know it's still a lot of people
and I think one person uh whether it was
uh someone close to you or that person
in the office that handles that the
accounting
it matters
so this is earned you earn it it's
whether it's accrued or it's or if it's
you get so much a year you could prorate
that it's a matter of the understanding
is that's mine I'm earning and it's part
of the work I'm doing for the company
it's only fair that it is mine on the
event of the
departure that the termination of the
deployment
you know I don't want to get in a debate
with you I'm happy you're here to defend
the bill and give us answers so but it
remember we're not talking about 20
percent of the population we're talking
about 20 percent of the people who file
with the labor board and I have no idea
how those cases came out maybe 19
percent of them won
that I'm sorry it was certainly not 19
it's a rarity it's a rarity that that
people Prevail either because they
misunderstood or misread didn't follow
the policy or because of this disclaimer
that trumps all reason and and justice
and I will get you information about how
many and how many people how many claims
I will get that to the committee
any yes represent Kim brawls thank you
Mr chair
um again I haven't been in the industry
for a long time in industry for a long
time I would argue that it's far worse
to have a use it or lose it policy
because it forces the employee to take
the time and then they lose it at the
end of the year if they don't take it
whereas I know many companies or most
companies allow you to accrue it and
then they certainly do pay you when you
retire or when you leave they do pay off
the vacation so again for if if I were I
would have gone further with this bill
if you really wanted to protect the
people I would have try to eliminate the
policy of use it or lose it because
that's where most of the hours are lost
I'll guarantee you that
uh
interesting you should mention that
because my co-sponsor Mr renzullo we
began this on two separate bills he was
he was opposed to user to lose it and I
was working on the vacation time and we
tried this the first time separate and
then we co-sponsored each other's bills
and then we pulled our resources and I
as I recall I even had one other
previous time that we made it through
the house and to the Senate we had a
provision that in the event that the
employer denied the vacation request and
you couldn't use it you get 90 days to
work that out or be paid again the
people on the other side of the hall
didn't didn't support that but it is a
it is a worthy topic for future
consideration and I mean I know that in
the case of the vacation uh the the
department does not track the calls that
they get but there are quite a few this
is they described it as being a heavy
hitting issue
and those who go through the claim uh
very rarely prevail
it does happen I've seen a few it has to
be you know that the policy wasn't exist
or it was silent or it was practiced
differently for different people but it
is it is an issue and certainly I would
I would certainly take a look at the
user to lose it part in a subsequent
year
thank you and again the numbers it would
be interesting to know the total numbers
so we could do a better assessment I
think I'll do that thank you
representative Hewitt
yes um I have RSA 275 43 in front of me
uh as As a matter of law there isn't any
law that affects people in New Hampshire
that requires uh unpaid or unpaid leave
time and so forth but the way the law is
written it certainly is open to the
negotiation and to Union contracts and I
suggest that there are some unions I
think if you contacted the International
Association of firefighters you'd find
that there are a large number of fire
departments in this country that do have
those those Provisions specifically
because that's an unusual type of
occupation you don't find too many you
don't find too many people get into that
that field other than working for a
government agency
and so uh it certainly is something that
can be the subject of negotiation and a
contract but it isn't something that's
required by law it doesn't require the
foreign
yes uh the law there is no requirement
that that an employer offer paid time
off vacation Etc
uh and and as far as vacation wages are
is when wages are due and as up to the
employer occurring to determine if
vacation wages are part of their policy
or not and I think in in most cases the
majority of cases as
Mr Columbus said Campbell said it is
sort of generally pop generally
expected and done but this is the case
these are for the cases and there are
see no further questions uh thank you
representative Cahill I think like yeah
we're gonna have some discussion yes
representative Weiler
oh thanks to Mr Hoffman I just got H.R
17. which has the estimates which are
troubling
I'm looking at this green sheet from the
governor which showed
General funds and I believe it doesn't
include
the
education trust fund so it's just the
and it shows going from
the adjusted authorized
1837 and so on
to
a 1 billion eight seventy seven so
there's only a 40 million dollar
increase and then
and upload from 2023 to 2020
for
it's about
million yet everybody's coming to us
asking for more and the
pay raise alone is a hundred million
right
yeah just shy of 100 million Mike Kane
did give me a note that said for 23 the
estimates are 42.7 million dollars below
the governors
and for 24.25 the estimates are
88.3 below the governors and that's
combined education fund and general fund
23 below and then 88 below for FY 23
42.7 below
and for the 24-25 Diana biennium
88.3 below
yeah and
this doesn't even cover this pay raise
which we're told is not negotiable
all it leaves us with is moving money
around everywhere else in the budget
just to cover the pay raise never mind
giving anybody an increase of 10 percent
four percent five percent there's no
money and the pay raises haven't been
factored into any of the budgets in
house bill one
that's that's likely it I thought they
were but
no they're not
so
it's not in here we don't have it and
what what we told Mike that the hb2
alone was had
yeah if the pay raise is around an hb2
is this the total in hb2
okay here's my question for house bill
74.
are we allowed to deliberately say no
recommendation or can you only have no
recommendation when it's split we've got
to create a balanced budget no no I'm
sorry he's talking about seven I'm cut
I'm I'm back to representative Cahill's
bill
I understand we got a serious problem
over there but
um
my question is on House Bill 74 can we
send it back to the floor with no
recommendation because it's really not
yeah it you ought to have some
dispositive thing like either itl or you
know and I mean I think everybody would
just vote the way they voted right I
mean
now we could go back to the full
committee with a recommendation and it
might be
if we vote ought to pass we've got to
fit into the budget
yeah well even if it's four and a half
million
okay
yeah we will vote we'll vote on
everything one way or the other you can
vote to retain it in hopes that they'll
do something like they did two years ago
oh we found another 50 million 100
million yeah after we did redid it of
course
March and April of big months
and Senate gets to look at them we don't
so if if they suddenly come up and we've
also been reading through the newspaper
and so on oh the revenues are coming in
well there are 80 million or the 50
million above above projected
which now we're seeing projections that
you know like you said with 23 million
behind what the governor says for 2023.
and even though we're above plan of
we're going down yeah we're actually
going down
yeah and and some of this Revenue that
they come up with looks pretty flat
going forward as a matter of fact for
the hr17
they show committee estimate I'm
assuming this is billions three billion
115 million hundred thousand that would
be based upon both
trust fund education trust fund and
general fund and then they they go into
fiscal year 24 3 billion one hundred and
thirty four thousand 134 million which
is you know it's 19
million more than 2023 and then they go
into
2025 3 billion 135 already going up a
million
24 to 25 and
they're they're going up some in in uh
in 23 to 24 but not nearly enough to
cover all the things that we've heard
in our deliberations that's the problem
I encounter when
we should have had this figure the same
day we got the budget we've always had
it in the past when you give us this
kind of bad news after we sat here and
told kind of encouraged people tacitly
by not saying no no no
kind of tastly so okay how much more do
you need and what do you need this for
and I know the governor didn't give it
to you maybe we can give it to you we
can't even give you what the governor
promised
so it puts us in a tough position
represent Griffin well it helps moving
forward I'll make a motion that we
retain this
uh bill
it's been moved in second and
um see no further discussion I'm sorry
representative Kayla we're now in our
voting stage so because Mr Mr erlinghill
said you needn't worry about this as far
as the budget
um
when we're behind and what the budget
that's been handed to us
every nickel counts all right the motion
has been made and seconded to retain
this bill
um the clerical as their discussion yes
representative McGuire yeah I'm I'm
actually so I voted against the bill but
when it came out but I'm with
representative Cahill in the sense that
I don't think this bill affects the
budget all right this up to four and a
half million I think up to could be zero
right so so
I I think he's right and and and that
um Charlie allenhouse said that it's de
minimis meaning almost nothing and to me
that I think that's correct this is a
standard labor bill that really is not
about government right it's about
everybody else right it's likely not to
affect government employees exactly and
so therefore my preference would be to
have it come out of the finance
committee with no recommendation because
on the basis that it has no budget right
aspect so
that's my thing I don't think that the
clerk will accept that coming from the
second okay well then itl or ought to
pass whatever because even when it came
to the flow with no recommendation yeah
they had to be a dispositive motion I
understand
ought to pass or Ito yeah I'm going to
support representative Griffin's motion
uh this budget you know looking at again
our financial
responsibilities as a division
it's going to at least affect 850 State
Employees as a fiscal note says and it
could be up to 4.5 million dollars in
general funds so I think
um again that's my statement on it
representative evil
also support representative Griffin's
motion but um
I actually would like to hear from uh
Das
indepen not that I question what you're
but it would be nice to have their
roles
I know we're looking at this strictly as
a financial thing because it's our job
but um I I don't see the Merit of this
bill knowing that the type of economy
that we're in right now it's just good
business to take care of your employees
and to pay the vacation pay I think this
is needless legislation and I would ask
my representative friend to withdraw his
motion so that another motion may be
president Griffin comments I'm willing
to withdraw on the basis that an Ito
okay is there a second to that motion
second second by representative McGuire
again the motion is to itl
uh I was still 74 FN
seeing no further discussion like the
clerk to please call the roll
this is
an expedient to legislate um
spill 74.
when I call your name multiply the cea
yay
yes
representative
representative Hewitt
name
representative email
hey
cheers
yes
and
um
yes
12 being one two three five two
okay the motion being five to three itl
okay being a little after 11 30 we'll
move on to House Bill 234 relative to
renewable energy credits
I believe this bill came to us came off
was taken off the table at the last
session of my memory serves me correctly
well just you have like a five minute
Hi how are you
I'm great how are you good thanks and if
you could please state your name for the
record please and I will allow the LBA
to hand out some of your testimony
um
thank you very much for
hearing House Bill 234 for the record my
name is representative Rebecca
McWilliams I represent South Concord and
you're actually in one of my floaterial
districts so it's a pleasure to host you
in my ward
um
so I'm going to give you a little bit of
a background and overview as to how we
got here and then hopefully talk about
what we can do for next steps moving
forward to resolve the conundrum that we
are in right now with the practice of
renewable energy credit or wreck
sweeping I'm going to do my best to
limit the number of acronyms that I use
but if I say something and it doesn't
make sense please let me know science
technology and energy is pretty
Technical and we have a lot of
abbreviations and I'm going to try to
spell it out for you so thank you for
your Indulgence on that
um
and I'm just waiting for the handouts to
all right I think we're good enough to
start
uh so what I've what I've handed out and
I'm going to talk to this a little bit
after I give a background
sorry the annual report from the
renewable energy fund from the most
recent report year but I'm not going to
dive into that quite yet it's highly
technical document let me just back up
and give you just a bit of an overview
of what New Hampshire does in regards to
our renewable portfolio standard or
affectionately known as RPS
um so I'm not familiar whether you've
been before a division like this before
but we try to focus on what the fiscal
impact okay on the state versus the
policy since the policy vote has already
occurred I mean we may get into some of
the policy but primarily what the fiscal
impact may be on the state's budget
thank you Mr chair so in terms of
renewable portfolio standard are you
familiar with our renewable portfolio
standard right now in terms of goals
not as well as I should be okay so I'll
just give you a little bit so you can
understand what it's all about
um because this bill impacts the
renewable portfolio standard and
therefore some Financial impacts
um so we have a renewable portfolio
standard requirement
um it's established four different
classes of renewable energy resources
this bill 234 really focuses on solar
okay so there are other renewable
resources things like wind Hydro
Etc but really this is all about solar
so uh the way this works is
we are required as a state
um
to push for certain percentage goals on
the renewable portfolio standard and the
Public Utilities Commission or puc
pushes these goals onto the utilities so
just as an example eversource is
required to hit a certain percentage
renewable portfolio standard by either
investing in Renewables or making
alternative compliance payments and they
have a choice as a business how they
want to do that but they are required to
meet these goals for the renewable
portfolio standard in around 2013
we had a decision by the legislature to
basically cut the way that this is done
we enabled Renewable Energy Credit
sweeping we created what we call the rec
loophole
um and so what that means is when you
have a solar customer who decides they
want to put solar on their own rooftop
generally this is residential but not
always it could be a small business
someone in New Hampshire decides they
want to put panels on the rooftop and
they are eligible for renewable energy
credits for those panels that they put
on the rooftop
however the paperwork is kind of a
hassle and the amount of money that you
make as a small producer is generally
between 20 and 40 dollars a year so
often renewable energy producers like
myself I have panels decide not to do
the process and not to apply and so
those wrecks are not applied they don't
go anywhere they aren't able to get the
benefit of the value of those wrecks
each year as that market and so we
created a bill wreck sweeping to allow
utilities to sweep those racks that
don't go claimed within a year and they
apply them to their renewable portfolio
standard requirement where they have to
hit a certain percentage with Renewables
generally solar is the one that they're
sweeping because that's what this bill
is about so we're talking about the
value and it really is a financial value
of those credits being
swept or gifted to our utilities the
actual value is somewhat in contest and
I think we would have to probably get
testimony from the utilities because
each one handles it differently they can
either do alternative compliance
payments or they can purchase renewable
energy credits but because they're
getting renewable energy credits for
free in the latest data it appears that
eversource for 2022 will be able to
break even and not need to make any
renewable energy credit purchases or
alternative compliance payments in order
to meet its report renewable portfolio
standard for for a mix why is this
important and why does it matter to
finance well obviously there's a dollar
value associated with that in terms of
where the money goes and how it's spent
so um those those alternative compliance
payments that this legislature in you
know 2009 when this all was set up we
intended as a legislature in 2009 that
those alternative compliance payments
made by utilities would go into the
renewable energy fund okay so we have a
bucket of money called the renewable
energy fund and it goes to various
sources and we'll get into the details
in the report that I distributed but the
intention there is to make sure that a
project that wouldn't pencil out without
a grant or some support from the
renewable energy fund does then pencil
out with those funds and we've seen that
the return on investment is either a
three to one or a four to one so it's
definitely worthwhile to have the bucket
of money in the renewable energy fund
and to make those grants available so
just for an example um let's just say
your high school is considering doing
biomass for heat and they know that the
cost is a hundred thousand dollars
approximately 17 of that or 17 000 could
be a grant from the renewable energy
fund and the remainder would be funded
by the town for the high school if that
makes sense so it makes it pencil when
otherwise it would not pencil to use the
money from the renewable energy fund so
the conundrum we find ourselves in right
now is unfortunately
um the renewable energy fund is not
receiving those alternative compliance
payments from the utilities because
they're wreck sweeping and they're
getting these free wrecks from people
who've decided not to apply for their
own wrecks and and therefore it has
undermined the entire intention of the
program because we end up not filling
out the renewable energy fund and not
being able to make these grants to
deserving applicants including our own
cities and towns
so just to get back to to the basics the
uh the average cost if we were to remove
Renewable Energy Credit sweeping wreck
sweeping is approximately six cents per
month for your average consumers this
would be residential electric rate pair
I do want to make a note that in 2013
when we decided as a legislature to do
some wreck sweeping
that Sixth Sense went from the um from
the rate pair to benefit the utility and
therefore it would have been a discount
right we should have seen six cents go
down in our in our bills but we didn't
we didn't see any change at all
and so it was kind of all you know
pennies here pennies there but big quick
picture the question is okay if six
cents just kind of disappeared there was
no puc rate case open for eversource to
say oh yeah I got the benefit of six
cents a month per utility payer uh
through Rec sweeping so therefore I
should reduce their bill didn't happen
Okay so all this is to say that um you
know it it does add up but the actual
value is really a question of what the
value is on the rec Market
so you may have heard testimony and I
just want to rebut the record for some
of the testimony you may have heard on
the house floor one of them was the
claim that this was a three million
dollar increase to rate payers every
year the three million dollars I
question that because it looks like Rex
are only selling at fifteen dollars
right now if Rex were selling at 55 I
think three million would make more
sense but because Rex you're selling at
15 I would say we're closer to a million
and then big picture are the utilities
actually going to adjust their rates to
address what is considered to be pennies
right now I don't think so I don't see
that being part of this
um so I think it's important to address
that piece and then another comment that
happened on the house floor during
debate was that um the department of
energy is actually neutral on this bill
and they testified at St that they're
neutral so they they have not officially
taken a stance as to whether they are
pro or against removing Wreck sweepings
All right so now I'm ready to dive into
the handouts that you've all received
let's start with page nine
okay
and this is in the overall Staples
annual report as well as Loosely
highlighted I didn't highlight the
report for you but here we go so we're
looking at the chart on the bottom in
regards to Alternative compliance
payments and we've talked about this in
2012 Class 2 which is our solar
we were making 168 dollars and 13 cents
at an old ACP payment rate
we lost two-thirds of that when wreck
sweeping happened in 2013 it went down
to 55 per
megawatt hour and so we lost two-thirds
of the value because we no longer had
those
um those credits available so that's the
history okay so I'm gonna have you turn
from that one to page 19 in your report
it looks like this big chart with
dollars small pie graph on the bottom
okay
so this is the example where you have a
project that may not pencil out without
the renewable energy fund Grant being
applied and so when we're looking at a
solar project the the pie chart is
really what I want to call your
attention to 87 percent
of whatever that project is is going to
be paid for either by the city the town
or it could be a private investor but
that that is not something that we are
handling as a legislature of the state
that 13 is the renewable energy fund
that kicks in as a grant to help get
this project across the finish line and
we certainly have seen that for example
um
you know we we have some State nursing
homes that do use biomass and we're able
to get that 13 renewable energy fund
investment to get over the finish line
and do the project
um
just want to be super clear on that one
all right now finally we're going to
turn to page 21
um of the renewable energy fund annual
report and this looks like chart on the
top two pie charts on the bottom
okay
okay so this is really focusing on
non-residential competitive grants so
we're really talking about
um
who benefits from the money in the
renewable energy fund if you look at the
chart that I've highlighted in the lower
left corner the pie chart shows that 48
percent are private entities and I it's
hard to read the printout so I put a
little color on it but 48 are private
entities which means that 52 percent
of those who are benefiting from the
residential I'm sorry non-residential
competitive grant our our municipalities
our schools wastewater treatment
facilities and County government so this
renewable energy fund is really
benefiting us and we're able to take it
home and bring home the bacon to our own
constituents through the renewable
energy fund so all of this is really
kind of a background to say that we have
the vehicle in the renewable energy fund
unfortunately we have removed the
ability to fund it through alternative
compliance payments because we've been
giving wrecks to utilities for free and
so therefore the dollars that we have
right now to deal with are about
two-thirds less than they would have
been if we had not done Rec sweeping and
so that's kind of my Dollar's
description I'll I'll let me go through
that one more time
so
right now
uh what we have is
a renewable energy fund that's set up
it's about it's a vehicle to receive
money from alternative compliance
payments that are paid by the utilities
or they could also invest in wrecks they
could be buying wrecks as well so they
have two ways of getting money into the
um the fund
so that's the intention there is to fund
it we set it up so that we could get
these benefits for our own cities and
towns
um two-thirds of it has basically been
removed from 2012 to 2013 because we got
rid of the ability for utilities to make
those alternative compliance payments
they simply swept the wrecks instead to
apply to the renewable portfolio
standard and therefore we no longer have
that huge benefit that pays off three to
one or four to one for our cities and
towns because we've basically given free
money to utilities and you've probably
heard all the other policy arguments but
this is just the financial description
of what's happening right now with the
renewable portfolio standard being met
through Rex sweeping and therefore
alternative compliance payments and Rex
not being purchased and therefore
renewable energy fund being completely
depleted thank you representative
McGuire has a question yes thank you
representative
um
you said that racks are now at fifteen
dollars but the alternative compliance
payment on this chart is more like 60 or
something right excellent point okay so
would there be any why are there any
alternative compliance payments wouldn't
wouldn't the utility just go by the
wreck for fifteen dollars instead of 60.
you know that's really an Ever Source
question because that's exactly what
they're doing right now they're a very
large utility they manage portfolios in
multiple States so the easiest and
simplest thing to do and by the way that
55 is set in statute so that's a puc
decision to make it 55 but the actual
Market is 15. so eversources made the
decision because they're big and I'll
let them speak for themselves if they're
here but they're big so they've decided
it's easier for us to just do this and
make the payment and move on rather than
hunting for renewable energy credits to
make the purchase from local energy
suppliers so they could but they're not
oh I see so you're saying they do make
alternative compliance payments well
they're they're making a very small
amount
um as of 2021 whatever as of 2022
they'll have swept everything so they
don't need to make those ACP payments
anymore right let me make so is the only
source of money to the renewable energy
fund these alternative compliance
payments or are there other places other
things that yes that's it okay and so
your main goal is more money in the
renewable energy fund right if if the
wreck value went back to people like
yourself
instead of going to eversource
right so you there are people that that
get their wrecked value because they
apply for it and they get it they get
twenty to forty dollars but but if all
the people who are getting swept If
instead they actually got the value of
their racks that would not satisfy you
because your main goal is to get more
money into this fund is that right
so it's it's a two-pronged problem okay
as an attorney
I am concerned about
robbing Peter to pay Paul right the
people who these wrecks belong to it's a
taking they don't have notice so that's
its own issue in terms of making them
whole and allowing them to have their
wrecks or making it an opt-out rather an
opt-in there's things you could do there
but it's a problem right now the way
it's being administered it's right per
class action lawsuit leaving that aside
the intention of the renewable energy
fund the whole purpose was to create a
bucket to to then collect these monies
from the utilities and benefit our
cities and towns and our constituents
who need additional Grant funds to
pencil a project but let's back up for a
second let's take take a quick look at
what we're doing as a state when we talk
about our renewable portfolio standard
okay we've set percentage goals that
through the pcpuc our utilities need to
hit those renewable portfolio standard
goals economically I think you're all in
this room because you understand the
finances of Economics we do not want to
have just one or two different types of
energy in our pool that we're using for
New Hampshire because it subjects us to
Market volatility right so that's kind
of the situation we've unfortunately
ended up in right now due to
International demand for natural gas and
of course the situation in Ukraine okay
so we have this portfolio that is made
up of mostly natural gas with you know
some nuclear and some other small hydro
and very small solar but our portfolio
is really heavily natural gas right now
the renewable portfolio standard was
intended to diversify our mix and so by
allowing Rec sweeping and undermining
the intention of the renewable portfolio
standard where you could either do buy
more wrecks purchase more wrecks or make
alternative compliance payments that was
to incentivize utilities to mix it up
and get more Renewables in the mix so
we're not so dependent on fossil fuels
just because financially it hurts us as
a state and so undermining the renewable
portfolio standard by continuing to
allow Rec sweeping is actually hurting
our our investment mix
let me let me ask it this way so is the
amount being swept
that actually is solar power right or do
you argue that that's that's wrong that
the amount being swept
doesn't really exist oh it certainly
exists it's a dollar value because it's
cost avoided on the utilities what I'm
saying is it represents actual solar
power right like yours you said yours is
being swept right mine is not actually
being swept oh okay for work and I get
my twenty dollars
so
some other person Mr Jones or there's
somebody there's this being swept right
so that's actual solar power
it's the value of the renewable energy
certificates right so so at the time the
solar turns into electricity you have
your wreck as soon as it converts yeah
so but my point is it's not that
you're you're saying that the the
purpose of the program is being uh
compromised but not really right because
the amount being swept is actual solar
power and so we are producing from solar
yes or or no okay so I think when when
you say it's not being compromised
because there is some solar applied to
unitils RPS requirement right there is
some solar it is being applied to
unitil's RPS requirement right but it's
not their solar they haven't gone out
and found a local supplier to support
and they certainly haven't paid the
puc's 55 for an alternative compliance
payment so they found a loophole
we've created a loophole so what's
happening here is it doesn't belong to
Unitil but we've allowed them to kind of
reach in and grab it and then they have
cost avoided by doing that but they also
don't meet the goals not really because
they're not doing what we set them up to
do
representative Ebel followed by
representative Weiler
um thank you Mr chair and thank you for
all your explanations so now I'm going
to ask a question which may indicate
that I don't really understand but
um I'm trying to a lot of what we're
talking about here seems like a policy
discussion and so what I'm trying to
figure out is you know we're supposed to
be assessing the fiscal effect on the
budget so
could you explain that
because I don't
I don't see a lot but that's what I I
mean it says here it wouldn't impact
revenues and it says expenditures are
I can't see where the expenditure is
here unless I I don't
I questioned why this was an FN bill
I haven't received a really good
explanation as to why this is an FN bill
I imagine there might be a slightly
reduced administrative cost of the
actual
um fund
possibly but the actual wreck sweeping
process of taking certificates from
residential solar producers who do not
fill out the paperwork and applying it
to utilities there may be some saved
administrative cost on that through this
bill possibly
likable State counties and and local
governments might see their electricity
increase by an indeterminable amount but
I
I mean that's
feels to me really
stretching the possibility of
anyway to me I don't see a big effect on
the budget and certainly nothing that we
would pencil in anywhere
thank you representative Ebel for the
comment slash question
um I would say that once again when we
when this took effect in 2013 we didn't
see any evidence of lowering rates from
the utilities there was no puc case open
to say we need to save our ratepayers
and funds because we've decided to do
wreck sweeping and likewise if we were
to remove sweat wreck sweeping I do not
expect to see a puc case open to say
this is going to increase because it's
de minimis it's six cents per per um per
thank you Mr chairman
so you have solar on your roof
it's Grandma but okay
how do you get paid for that did they
deduct it off your electric bill
for my residential solar I have a
ground-mounted solar system solar array
and each month I have a negative
electric bill from Unitil so it's and
once a year I have an opportunity to
contact Unitil and say I'd like that
negative credit applied to a different
bill
but I don't ever see a check
so with that negative credit they in
effect are buying electricity they are
buying solar generated electricity from
you which is a renewable
yes so when they sweep it
they're taking the credit for that same
as they would for any other
so I've generated that that was a
renewable so I don't see why that's the
wrong thing to do they have paid you
for that electricity so they are taking
credit for a renewable thing so I don't
see why you object to that because
overall it's it's helping us all plus
the fact that
they go to the Public Utilities
Commission on a regular basis for rate
adjustments
and they're allowed a return on
investment or they would just go out of
business so even though there are Public
Utilities they're very controlled they
have to show all their expenses
including all the ice storms and all the
outages and all the things they've had
to be to be repaired so every year
they're trying for every last dollar
so if if your bill passes they're going
to have to give you some money and it's
going to come out of all the other rate
payers it's my only conclusion in this
in this Bill thank you
can I respond to that
okay um first I just want to explain how
the process works so yes I'm a solar
producer at my house and there are times
when I get a credit for producing more
solar than I use but I don't ever get a
check for it it's just a a negative
balance there is a bright line between
that
and actually applying for doing the
paperwork and getting renewable energy
certificate for what I'm producing which
is then sold at auction four times a
year and the value that comes back at
auction can come to me in the form of a
check where I actually receive funds but
if I fail to fill out the paperwork then
that value gets swept by Unitil my
utility and they get the dollar value so
there's a there's a strong difference
between actually what I'm doing with my
bill which never turns into any real
dollars and the certificates which are
solid dollars and that's the piece that
the utilities are able to sweep and
apply to their own benefit okay so I
want to be really clear that
um
there are two different pieces to it
okay then you had you had a comment
about
um cost shifting which
is not actually what's happening cost
shifting is when other people are paying
the bill for someone who has something
that we consider to be new novel or in
this case we started doing solar and
there were questions about whether when
people put solar on their own house is
there cost shifting to their neighbors
who don't have solar so I have really
great news that we had a long-awaited
report from the Department of energy
that came out about a month and a half
ago where it was determined that in the
absolute most conservative case this
this study was done before the right
rate spikes with natural gas so this is
you know based on about 2020 cost of
electricity in the most conservative
case if there is cost shifting it's 1.5
percent which is once again considered
to be de minimis very small amount not
something a conservative case not
something that we need to be concerned
about when it comes to making policy for
future Solar Development in the state so
we have the data on that and it was a
concern and which is why we waited to do
major solar bills until after we got the
so my question is are rates are based on
or what the utilities are allowed to
rate US at allowed against their income
and their expenses and they have a
bottom line so when these are swept by
the utilities are you saying that
they're not
blended into that formula or are they do
they uh are they applied as income for
the utility or not is it an equal value
or not
I think that would be a question for the
utilities as to how they actually handle
the value of the wrecks that they sweep
but my point was there was no puc case
opened at the time that they got the
benefit of those wrecks which would have
meant Sixth Sense increase or I'm sorry
six seven decrease at the time 2013 it
would have been meant about six cent
decrease on average to all ratepayers so
I'm not going to say that absence of
evidence is the conclusion here but also
it's a question as to how the utilities
determine the value of avoided Rec
purchases or alternative compliance
payments so when you're doing your
bookkeeping how do you put a value on
that avoided cost I'm not sure that's
really a utility question so if I may in
other words the consumers not seeing any
uh discernible value from the credits
that they're sweeping the utilities
there's there's not a tangible rate
decrease to the consumers that where
they would be if it was a normal income
accounted item agree yes thank you agree
representative Griffin
I've been in business most of my life I
kind of agree with the the chair
representative Wyler that
when you take when you take income away
from a business
they work hard to replace it and we know
in this state
that one of the things that holds us
back and holds back the growth of
industry is high electrical rates
and it's a penny here and a penny there
it's like Everett Dirksen said a
millionaire a million there pretty soon
you're talking about big money
and
it's just inevitable that when you take
something away from the utility they're
going to figure out how to get it back
so in response to that I would say we
have short-term and long-term thinking
on how the utilities manage their
business and they are controlled you're
absolutely right they're a monopoly and
they have tight constraints because we
want to make sure that they aren't
hurting rate payers that being said when
we're talking about six cents plus or
minus pre-2013 post 2013. we're talking
about Sixth Sense
and then we're talking about the
long-term goal of the renewable
portfolio standard was to require
utilities to start purchasing renewable
energy credits and to diversify their
mix therefore get us off of this
International volatile rate situation so
the long-term goal here 10 years out is
to not be so reliant on only two major
energy sources in New Hampshire that's
why we set up the renewable portfolio
standard and that's why we told the
utilities they had to meet those
percentage requirements and they had you
know the carrot and the stick the stick
was if you don't do it you're going to
have to buy rex or you're going to have
to make alternative compliance payments
so by giving them this free pass
we went back to short-term thinking and
we said okay now it's just about the
pennies it's just about getting by year
to year and we're not looking at the big
picture long-term goal which is really
10 years from now we don't want our
Energy Mix as a state to just be two two
major sources we want it to be diverse
any more questions for representative
McWilliams seeing one represent people I
mean isn't the concept that you just
described that ultimately our overall
electricity rates should be going down
expanding the pie the pie
um I mean
I guess again I would just ask
this has a fiscal note I'm just not
seeing other than the policy discussion
what effect this has on the budget so I
have a I have a problem
voting on it other than the way the
I'm free we're not going to take any
more questions on this so we're well
past our time the policy committee what
speaking of the policy I know was taken
off the table last week
was it without recommendation or was it
itl ought to pass out of Science and
Technology do you recall it was evenly
split evenly split thanks you're welcome
uh seeing more no more questions from
the division
um
is there a motion or thought what the
division would like to do representative
evil I'll just go ahead and make make a
motion and then we can talk about it I
think I've already expressed my concern
that we're really focused on the policy
here and I think there's Divergent
opinions but if we're here to talk about
the effect on the budget I don't really
see one so on that basis and adhering to
the reason that we're here
um the the house voted ought to pass and
I would make a motion about to pass I
second that motion the motion's been
made and seconded by representative
hatch to pass this uh
due to its uh
apparent lack of impact on the state's
budget then I mean and yes I do support
the policy but I'm what I'm really doing
is supporting them the
um house vote in favor of this
all right is there more discussion
representing camberells yes thank you Mr
chair well having come from sdne last
session I'm well versed on this subject
matter and
um there's no doubt in my mind that
although it may not affect the state
budget this affects the rate payers and
I know we're not here again not here to
discuss policy we'll discuss uh you're
here to discuss the financial impact but
uh I believe that when you impact our
rate payers uh you're impacting the
state and uh the again the these swept
wrecks serve no per the people that are
voluntarily not signed up to get credit
for their wrecks it's just wasted it
just just sits there I see no problem
with the utilities sweeping them and
then returning that back to the
ratepayers in the form of a rebate
whether it's six cents or six dollars
um it there's no doubt that it goes back
to the rape payer
and so
I I would I would personally have made
an itl motion but I know where we have
another motion on the table right now
represent Griffin I would second the
comments that were just made
inevitably it's going to affect the rate
and that means it's going to affect the
town
City
the county and the state
and most importantly all our
constituents
maybe represent Maguire thank you well
let me tell you the idea I came in here
with today which is that representative
evil is is completely correct this is it
has nothing to do with the budget but we
have to pass do something with it right
you know put in our lap so I personally
my personal prediction is that assuming
this Bill gets as it is to the Senate
and or governor
that's going to be the end they're not
going to go for it okay so I had an idea
to to change it in the following way
instead of the swept money going to the
rate payer or to the utility however you
think it goes what if we send it back to
the people being swept namely the
generators right so if you're you know
if you're a little piece of this money
is ten dollars then you get the ten
dollars okay and so
um it would still be swept so you don't
have to bother with the paperwork but
your utility knows who you are so why
not send you back that value right and
so
um that was my idea for a change and I
think
you know
that has a possibility of at the end of
the day becoming law so
but if if you know maybe that's a bill
for next year rather than this year I
don't know I think your latter comment
would be correct representative required
uh yes representative Griffin
I just say one thing about uh
representative McGuire's idea I had
thought about the same thing why in fact
I almost asked the person testifying why
hasn't this bill just give it to
everybody who's earning it
but I think again what's going to happen
is
there's going to be some shifting
there's going to be some shifting of
cost because
the
the rate is going to go up as a result
of that but the electric rate
representative evil is it not true that
um this regardless of what we do here
it's going to go to full finance and
then it's going to go back to the floor
again that's correct
so we'll just make a recommendation one
way or the other
support your emotions motion and just
let it pull yeah we could support your
motion and let the full committee debate
it next week or the week after
I mean it is a philosophically pure
emotion I would argue you are correct
about that
I'm ready to call about
the clerk is ready to call represent
no
nay
foreign
we're going to start going over the
budget Page by Page and line by line and
and there's a list of things that in hb2
that we finally have that are strictly
in division one
now with this news we have of not having
anywhere near the revenue that the
governor has projected and spent
and
our our LBA people our LBA people can
steer you to the
the
pages you'll have that you can go
through quickly
banking insurance no general fund yes
they're they're going to get the money
wherever they have to get it we don't
have to worry about it but we want to
concentrate on getting through those as
quickly as we can and Mike will tell you
which pages that you can do away with
because they don't depend on general
so
get through those so you can sit down
and see
my estimate is we're going to have to be
making some Cuts now I'm going to rely
on going to division two and what I did
see in hb2 that I liked was
we give so much money to the education
trust fund that now we don't know what
to do with all that money we're going to
use it where we used to put general fund
into building Aid and and special ed and
all those things they say well you can
use that out of the education trust fund
there's too much money going into the
education trust fund that needs to go
elsewhere where all the other demands
are so one of the things that was in
there was the governor's taken business
Enterprise tax business profits tax
where 50 of it used to go to the
education trust fund he's changed it to
35 percent and I think meals and rooms
he's done the same instead of giving as
much it's going to 35 percent we'll take
a look at that and I know the LBA will
will advise us what those effects will
be we don't need as much money going to
the education trust fund last last
session we gave away 100 million it's a
swept which none of us have yet seen on
our property tax bills it should have
reduced them all a couple hundred bucks
a piece never happens as long as the
schoolers they're spending all they can
see in sight so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go to division two
and try to get the education trust fund
changed so that more money is left in
the general fund because we need it and
all these other things and especially if
we're going from division to division
you're going to have trouble balancing
the budget they'll have more money left
plus they don't have to worry about Dot
and safety get they're not going to get
money as much money from General funds
as they might thought they were and
they're all planning on buying more
cruises and all this other stuff the
money isn't there
unless unless more money comes in the
highway fund and as long as people keep
buying electric cars and getting 30
miles a gallon it's a whole other it's
going to keep going down so is it your
job to give us a total for our section
yes yes with a lot of help from the
experts
you know which is last time you might
remember because some some of us were
here
we had to cut 70 million
and we took a look at the fact that the
previous budget there was a hundred
million which should have gone for
one-time projects but instead they put
it all into HHS HHS couldn't hire enough
people to find enough space to put them
to work so that hundred million is 80
million of it still left in HHS and
we've got to cut 70 million there it is
they had
listed for 3 600 employees they had
2300.
once you take away all those employees
they didn't hire
we've balanced the budget I don't know
as we'll have something that easy again
but I'm going to be looking
so you'll find it
I'll do my best
well you you have so many different
plots and you only have a few that have
funded other than general fund
yeah so
well I just I haven't thought of it that
foreign
so yeah
I I move retained
technically
well they'll have to go be the official
thing that was always done in the past
that they failed to do this year was
prior to February 15th they would come
before the house they would make a
presentation and they would pass a
resolution this time it's H.R 17. okay
that's finding upon us that's law upon
us
we can't go over that
so we sit down with a budget and two
years ago it was a 70 million dollar
difference
that's better than the 250 million I
first looked at it yeah that would give
you gray hair well we're talking about
here